‏eh
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
حي على
الصلاه ح على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلا الله
اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
استقيم اعتدل استو سو الصف سد
الخلل اقيموا صفوفكم يت
لا الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليه
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولا تجادلوا اهل الكتاب الا بالتي هي
احسن الا الذين ظلموا
منهم وقولوا
امنا بالله الذي انزل
الينا وقولوا امنا بالذي انزل الينا وانزل
اليكم والهنا والهكم واحد ونحن له
مسلمون وكذلك
انزلنا اليك
الكتاب فالذين اتيناهم الكتاب يؤمن
به ومن
هؤلاء من يؤمن
به وما يجحد
باياتنا الا
الكافرون وما كنت تتلو من قبله من كتاب
ولا تخطه
بيمينك اذا ارتاب
المبطلون بل هو ايات بينات
في صدور الذين اوتوا
العلم وما يجحد
باياتنا الا
الظالمون وقالوا لولا انزل عليه ايات من
ربه قل
انما الايات عند
الله
وانما انا
نذير مبين وقالوا لولا انزل عليه ايات من
ربه قل
انما الايات عند
الله
وانما انا نذير مبين اولم يكفهم انا
انزلنا عليك الكتاب يتلى
عليهم ان ان في ذلك
لرحمه وذكرى لقوم
يؤمنون قل كفى بالله بيني وبينكم
شهيدا يعلم ما في السماوات
والارض والذين امنوا بالباطل وكفروا بالله
اولئك هم
الخاسرون
يستعجلونك بالعذاب
ولولا اجل
مسما
لجاءهم
العذاب وليات
نهم بغته وهم لا
يشعرون
يستعجلونك بالعذاب
وان جهنم
لمحيطه بالكافر
يوم يغشاهم العذاب من فوقهم ومن تحت
ارجلهم ويقول ذوقوا ما كنتم
تعملون يا عبادي الذين امنوا ان ارضي
واسعه فاياي
فاعبدون كل نفس
ذا ذائقه
الموت
ثم الينا
ترجعون والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
لنبوئنهم
من
الجنه
غرفا غرفا تجري من تحتها الانهار خالد
فيها خالدين فيها نعم اجر
العاملين الذين صبروا وعلى ربهم
يتوكلون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
وكاي من
دابه لا تحمل رزقها الله يرزقها
واياكم وهو السميع العليم ولئن سالتهم من
خلق السماوات والارض وسخر الشمس
والقمر
ليقولن الله
فانا
يؤفكون الله يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء من عباده ويقدر له ان الله بكل شيء
عليم
ولئن
سالتهم من نزل من
السماء
ماء
فاحيا فاحيا به الارض من بعد
موتها
ليقول
الله قل الحمد لله بل اكثرهم لا
يعقلون وما هذه الحياه الدنيا الا له
ولعب وان الدار الاخره لهي
الحيوان لو كانوا
يعلمون فاذا ركبوا في
الفلك دعوا الله مخلصين له الدين فلما
نجاهم الى البر اذا هم
يشركون ليكفروا
بما اتي هم
وليتمتعوا
وليتمتعوا فسوف
يعلمون اولم يروا انا جعلنا حرما
امنا ويتخطف الناس من
حولهم افبالباطل
يؤمنون وبنعمه الله
يكفرون ومن اظلم م من افترى على الله كذبا
او كذب بالحق لما
جاءه اليس في
جهنم مثوا
للكافرين والذين جاهدوا فينا
لنهدينهم
سبلنا
وان الله لمع
المحسنين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله اياك
ن الله
اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
سلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
السلام
عل ان شا
الله
الله الله
شا اللهن
تالى ان شاء الله
جزاك الله
[Silence]
خير
‏s
[Silence]
‏k
استقيموا اعتدلوا
استووا سووا
الصف الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين
الم
م غلبت الروم في ادنى الارض وهم من بعد
غلبهم
سيغلبون في بضع سنين لله الامر من قبل ومن
بعد ويومئذ
يفرح
المؤمنون بنصر الله ينصر من يشاء وهو
العزيز
الرحيم وعد الله لا يخلف الله وعده ولكن
اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون يعلمون ظاهرا من الحياه الدنيا وهم
عن الاخره هم
غافلون اولم يتفكروا في
انفسهم ما خلق الله السماوات والارض وما
بينهما الا بالحق واجل
مسمى وان كثيرا من
الناس وان كثيرا من الناس
بلقاء ربهم
لكافرون اولم يسيروا في الارض فينظروا كيف
كان عاقبه الذين من
قبلهم كانوا اشد منهم قوه واثاروا الارض
وعمروها وعمروها اكثر مما
عمروها
وجاءتهم رسلهم بالبينات فما كان الله
ليظلمهم ولكن كانوا
انفسهم
يظلمون ثم كان عاقبه الذين
اساءوا
السوء ان كذبوا بايات الله ان كذبوا بايات
الله وكانوا بها
يستهزئون الله يبدا الخلق ثم ث يعيده ثم
اليه
ترجعون ويوم تقوم الساعه يبلس
المجرمون ولم يكن لهم من
شركائهم
شفعاء وكانوا
بشركائهم
كافرين ويوم تقوم الساعه يومئذ يتفرق
فاما الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات فاما الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات فهم في روضه روضه روضه
يحبرون واما الذين كفروا وكذبوا
باياتنا وكذبوا
باياتنا قاء الاخره فاولئك
فاولئك في العذاب
محضرون فسبحان الله حين تمسون وحين
تصبحون وله الحمد في السماوات والارض
وعشيا وحين
تظهرون يخرج الحي من الميت ويخرج الميت من
الحي ويحيي الارض بعد
موتها وكذلك
تخرجون ومن اياته ان خلقكم من
تراب ثم ان ثم اذا
انتم بشر
تنتشرون ومن اياته ان خلق لكم من
انفسكم
ازواجا
ازواجا لتسكنوا
اليها وجعل
بينكم موده ورحمه
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يتفكرون ومن اياته خلق السما ومن
اياته خلق السماوات
والارض
واختلاف الوان واختلاف السنتكم
والوانكم ان في ذلك لايات
للعالمين ومن اياته
منامكم بالليل
والنهار
وابتغاؤكم
من فضله ان في ذلك لا ايات لقوم
يسمعون ومن اياته ان يريكم البرق خوفا
وطمعا ومن اياته اي ومن اياته
يريكم ومن اياته يريكم البرق خوفا
وطمعا وينزل من
السماء
ماء فيحيي به
الارض فيحيي به الارض بعد
موتها ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يعقلون ومن اياته ان تقوم
السماء والارض
بامره ثم اذا دعاكم دعوه من الارض اذا ان
انت م
تخرجون وله من في السماوات والارض كل له
قانتون وهو الذي يبدا الخلق ثم يعيده وهو
اهون
عليه وله المثل الاعلى في السماوات والارض
وهو العزيز
الحكيم ضرب لكم
مثلا من
انفسكم هل لكم مما ملكت
ايمانكم من شركاء فيما
رزقناكم فانتم فيه
سواء
تخافونهم كخيفتكم
انفسكم كذلك نفصل الايات لقوم يعقلون
بل اتبع الذين ظلموا
اهواءهم بغير علم فمن يهدي من اضل الله
وما لهم من
ناصرين فاقم وجهك للدين
حنيفا فطره الله التي فطر الناس عليها لا
تبديل لخلق الله ذلك ك الدين القيم
ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون منيبين اليه واتقوه واقيموا
الصلاه واقيموا الصلاه ولا تكونوا من
المشركين من الذين فرقوا دينهم وكانوا
شيعا كل
حزب بما لديهم
فرحون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذا مس الناس ضر
دعوا ربهم منيبين اليه ثم اذا اذاقهم منه
رحمه اذا فريق منهم بربهم
يشركون ليكفروا بما
اتيناهم فتمتعوا فسوف
تعلمون ام
انزلنا عليهم
سلطانا فهو يتكلم بما كان به
يشركون واذا ذقنا الناس
رحمه فرحوا بها وان تصبهم سيئه بما قدمت
ايديهم اذا هم
يقنطون اولم يروا ان الله يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء
ويقدر ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يؤمنون فات ذا القربى حقه والمسكين وابنى
السبيل ذلك خير للذين يريدون وجه الله
واولئك هم
المفلحون وما اتيتم من ربا ليربو في اموال
الناس فلا يرض
فلا يربوا عند الله وما
اتيتم من زكاه تريدون وجه الله
فاولئك هم
المضعفون الله الذي خلقكم ثم
رزقكم ثم يميتكم ثم
يحييكم هل من
شركائكم من يفعل من ذلكم من شيء سبحانه
وتعالى
عما
تشركون
يشركون ظهر الفساد في البر والبحر بما
كسبت ايدي
الناس
ليذيقهم بعض الذي عملوا لعلهم
يرجعون قل سيروا في الارض فانظروا كيف كان
عاقبه الذين من
قبل كان اكثرهم مشركين فاقم وجهك للدين
حنيفا من قبل ان ياتي يوم من قبل ان ياتي
يوم لا مرد له من الله
فاقم وجهك للدين القيم من قبل ان ياتي يوم
لا مرد فيه من الله
يومئذ
يصدعون من كفر فعليه كفره ومن عمل صالحا
فلانفسهم
يمهدون ليجزي الذي الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات من فضله انه لا يحب
الكافرين ومن اياته ان يرسل الرياح
مبشرات وليذيقكم
من رحمته
ولتجعل
بامره ولتبتغوا من فضله ولعلكم تشكرون
ولقد ارسلنا من قبلك رسلا الى قومهم
فجاؤهم
بالبينات
فانتقمنا من الذين
اجرمو وكان حقا علينا نصر
المؤمنين الله الذي يرسل الرياح فتثير
سحابا فسقناه في
الله الذي يرسل الرياح فتثير سحابا فيبسطه
في
السماء كيف
يشاء ويجعله
كسفا فترى الودق يخرج من خلاله فاذا اصاب
به من
يشاء من
عباده اذا هم يستبشرون
وان كانوا من قبل ان ينزل عليهم من قبله
لمبلسين
فانظر الى اثار رحمه
الله كيف يحيي الارض بعد
موتها ان ذلك لمحيي الموتى وهو على كل شيء
قدير ولئن ارسلنا ريحا راوه مصفرا
لظلوا لظلوا من بعده
يكفرون فانك لا تسمع الموتى ولا تسمع
الصم الدعاء اذا ولوا
مدبرين وما انت بهادي العمي عن
ضلالتهم ان تسمع الا من يؤمن باياتنا فهم
مسلمون الله الذي خلقكم من ضعف ثم جعل من
بعد ضعف
قوه ثم جعل من بعد ضعف قوه ثم جعل من بعد
قوه ضعف ضعف ثم جعل من بعد ضع ضعف قوه ثم
جعل من بعد قوه
ضعفا وشيبه يخلق ما
يشاء وهو العليم القدير ويوم تقوم الساعه
يقسم المجرمون ما لبثوا غير
ساعه ويوم تقوم الساعه يقسم المجرمون ما
لبثوا ير ساعه كذلك كانوا
يؤفكون وقال الذين اوتوا العلم والايمان
لقد لبثتم في كتاب
الله لقد لبثتم في كتاب الله الى يوم
البعث فهذا يوم البعث
ولكنكم كنتم لا
تعلمون فيومئذ لا ينفع الذين ظلموا
معذرتهم ولا هم
يستعتبون ولقد ضربنا للناس في هذا القران
من كل
مثل ولئن جئتهم بايه
ليقولن الذين
كفروا
كفروا ان انتم الا
مبطلون كذلك يطبع الله على قلوب الذين لا
يعلمون فاصبر
ان وعد الله حق ولا
يستخفنك الذين لا
يوقنون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام الس عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
‏das
‏und haben
ne
ja
استقيم واستو ترص
اعتدلوا
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب الع
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
الم
م تلك ايات الكتاب
الحكيم هدى ورحمه
للمحسنين الذين يقيمون الصلاه ويؤتون
الزكاه وهم بالاخره هم
يوقنون ا ائك على هدى من ربهم
واولئك هم
المفلحون ومن الناس من يشتري لهو الحديث
ليضل عن سبيل الله بغير علم
ويتخذها
هزوا
اولئك لهم عذاب
مهين واذا تتلى عليه اياتنا واللام
مستكبرا كان لم يسمعها كان في اذنيه وقرا
فبشره بعذاب
اليم ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم
جنات
النعيم خالدين فيها وعد الله حقا وهو
العزيز
الحكيم خلق السماوات بغير عمد ترونها
والقى في الارض رواسي ان تميد بكم وبث
فيها من كل
دابه
وانزلنا من
السماء
ماء فانبتنا فيها من كل زوج
كريم هذا خلق الله فاروني ماذا خلق الذين
من دونه بل الظالمون في ضلال
مبين ولقد اتينا لقمان الحكمه ان اشكر
لله ومن يشكر فانما يشكر لنفسه ومن كفر
فان الله غني
حميد واذ قال لقمان لابنه وهو يعظه يا بني
لا شرك بالله ان الشرك لظلم
عظيم ووصينا الانسان بوالديه حملته امه
وهنا على وهن وفصاله في عامين ان اشكر لي
ولوالديك ان اشكر لي
ولوالديك الي المصير وان جاهداك على ان تش
شرك بيما ليس لك به علم فلا تطعهما
وصاحبهما في الدنيا
معروفا واتبع سبيل من اناب الي ثم الي
مرجعكم
فانبذ بما كنتم
تعملون يا بني انها ان تك مثقال حبه من خر
دل فتكن في صخره او في السماوات او في
الارض يات بها
الله ان الله لطيف
خبير يا بني اقم الصلاه وامر بالمعروف
وانهى عن المنكر واصبر على ما اصابك ان
ذلك لمن عزم
الامور ولا تصعر خدك ل الناس ولا تمش في
الارض مرحا ان الله لا يحب كل مختال
فخور واقصد في مشيك واغضب من صوتك ان انكر
الاصوات لصوت
الحمير الم تروا ان الله سخر لكم ما في
السماوات وما في الارض واسبغ عليكم عمه
ظاهره
وباطنه ومن الناس من يجادل في الله بغير
علم ولا هدى ولا كتاب
منير واذا قيل لهم اتبعوا ما
انزل الله قالوا بل نتبع ما وجدنا عليه
اباءنا اولو كان الشيطان يدعوهم الى عذاب
السعير الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين ومن يسلم وجهه الى الله وهو محسن فقد
استمسك بالعروه الوثقى والى الله عاقبه
الامور ومن كفر فلا يحزنك كفره الينا
مرجعهم ف ينبئهم بما عملوا ان الله عليم
بذات
الصدور نمتعهم قليلا ثم نضطرهم الى عذاب
غليظ ولئن سالتهم من خلق السماوات والارض
ليقولن الله قل الحمد لله بل اكثرهم لا
يعلمون لله ما في السماوات والارض ان الله
هو الغني
الحميد ولو ان ما في الارض من شجره اقلام
والبحر يمده من بعده سبعه ابحر ما نفدت
كلمات
الله ان الله عزيز حكيم ما خلقكم ولا
بعثكم الا كنفس واحده ان الله سميع
بصير الم تر ان الله يولج الليل في النهار
ويولج النهار في
الليل وسخر الشمس والقمر كل يجري الى اجل
مسمى وان الله بما تعملون خبير ذلك بان ان
الله هو الحق وان ما يدعون من دونه الباطل
وان الله هو العلي
الكبير الم تر ان الفلك تجري في البحر
بنعمه الله ليريكم من
اياته ان في ذلك لايات لكل
صبار شكور واذا غشيهم موج كالظلل دعوا
الله مخلصين له الدين فلما نجاهم الى البر
فمنهم مقتصد وما يجحد
باياتنا الا كل
ختار
كفور يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم واخشوا
يوما لا يجزي والد عن ولده لا يجزي والد
عن ولده ولا مولود هو جاز عن والده
شيئا ان وعد الله حق فلا
تغرنكم الحياه الدنيا ولا
يغرنكم بالله
الغرور ان الله عنده علم الساعه وينزل غيث
ويعلم ما في
الارحام وما تدري نفس ماذا تكسب غدا وما
تدري نفس باي ارض
تموت ان الله عليم
خبير الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله الله
[Silence]
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله وصحبه ومن ولاه ومن تبعه باحس
يوم
الدين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك وك محمد وعلى
اله وصحه
[Silence]
اجمعين
ع رض الله
عنصل عليه
[Silence]
واللام
جابن عبد الله ض
عنبور
رول
ابن
ع جرايل
عليهه
[Silence]
ع
بالالى
[Silence]
ح
صل
عل
again الم
المدثر عليه الصلاه والسلام يا ايها
المدثر قم فانذر وربك فكبر وثيابك فتحر
ورك
فحجر رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يا
ايها
المدثر ى الله عليه
وسلم عليهه والسلام
[Silence]
‏ofal us
there
right can be a can be
الله
[Silence]
سبال
مون
موون م
علسلام
[Silence]
علول
ملام الله
سالى
‏more days make
days tell
you0
days رسول الله صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
وسلم اقك الذ خلق خلق الانسان منق اقربك
الاكرم الذي علم القم الانسان ما
لمي
عليه
[Silence]
الهلام
so
عليه
[Silence]
الهلام
علال
[Silence]
انلام
اللهانه الله
سانال
‏qui
عليه
no
[Silence]
any عليه
اللاسلام الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
اله الله
مح
[Silence]
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذا القبر وقنا عبم
عتنه والمات وقنا عتنه المسيح الدجال ربنا
تقبلنا السميع العليم وتوب علينا يا مولاك
التواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى
اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك ارحم الراحمين
اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم امين واياكم
ان شاء
الله
استقيم
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا ال
ضين
امين
الم
م تنزيل الكتاب لا ريب فيه من رب
العالمين ام يقولون
افتراه بل هو الحق من ربك ذر قوما ما
اتاهم من نذير من قبلك لعلهم
يهتدون الله الذي خلق السماوات والارض وما
بينهما في سته ايام ثم استوى على
العرش ما لكم من دونه من ولي ولا
شفيع افلا تتذكر
رون يدبر الامر من
السماء الى الارض ثم يعرج اليه في
يوم كان مقداره الف سنه
مما
تعدون ذلك عالم الغيب والشهاده العزيز
الرحيم الذي احسن كل شيء خلقه وبدا خلق
الان ان من
طين
ثم جعل نسله من
سلاله من
ماء
مهين ثم سواه ونفخ فيه من روحه وجعل لكم
السمع والابصار
والافئده
قليلا ما
تشكرون وقالوا ائذا ضللنا في الارض اانا
لفي خلق
جديد بل هم
بلقاء ربهم
كافرون قل
يتوفاكم ملك الموت الذي وكل بكم ثم الى
ربكم
ترجعون ولو ترى اذ المجرمون ناكسوا رؤوسهم
عند ربهم ربنا ابصرنا وسمعنا فارجعنا نعمل
صالحا انا
موقنون ولو شئنا لاتينا كل نفس هداها ولكن
حق القول مني
لاملان جهنم من الجنه
والناس
اجمعين فذوقوا بما نسيتم
لقاء يومكم هذا انا
نسيناكم وذوقوا عذاب الخلد بما كنتم
تعملون انما يؤمن باياتنا الذين اذا ذكروا
بها خروا
سجدا خروا سجدا وسبحوا بحمد ربهم وهم لا
يستكبرون
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر تتجافى جنوبهم عن المضاجع يدعون ربهم
خوفا وطمعا
وم رزقناهم
ينفقون فلا تعلم نفس ما اخفي لهم من قره
اعين
جزاء بما كانوا
يعملون افمن كان مؤمنا كمن كان فاسقا لا
يستوون اما الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
لهم جنات الماوى نزلا بما كانوا
يعملون واما الذين فسقوا فما واهم
النار كلما ارادوا ان يخرجوا منها اعيدوا
فيها وقيل لهم ذوقوا عذاب النار الذي كنتم
به
تكذبون ولنذيقنهم
من العذاب الادنى دون العذاب الاكبر لعلهم
يرجعون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ولنذيقنهم
من العذاب الادنى دون العذاب الاكبر لعلهم
يرجعون ومن اظلم ممن ذكر بايات ربه ثم
اعرض عنها انا من المجرمين
منتقمون ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب فلا تكن
في مريه
من
لقائه وجعلناه هدى لبني
اسرائيل وجعلنا منهم
ائمه يهدون بامرنا لما صبروا وكانوا
باياتنا
يوقنون ان ربك هو يفصل بينهم يوم القيامه
فيما كانوا فيه
يختلفون
اولم يهد لهم كم اهلكنا من قبلهم من
القرون يمشون في
مساكنهم ان في ذلك لايات افلا
يسمعون اولم يروا انا نسوق
الماء الى الارض الجرز فتخرج فنخرج به
زرعا تاكل منه انعام
وانفسهم افلا
يبصرون ويقولون متى هذا الو ويقولون متى
هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين ويقولون متى هذا الفتح ان كنتم
صادقين قل يوم الفتح لا ينفع الذين كفروا
ايمانهم ولا هم
ينظرون فاعرض عن عنهم وانتظر
انهم
منتظرون الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العال
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
يا ايها النبي اتق الله ولا تطع الكافرين
والمنافقين ان الله كان عليما حكيما واتبع
ما يوحى اليك من ربك ان الله كان بما
تعملون
خبيرا وتوكل على الله وكفى بالله
وكيلا ما جعل الله رجل من قلبين في جوفه
وما جعل ازواجكم
اللائي تظاهرون منهن
امهاتكم وما جعل وما جعل
ادعياءكم
ابناءكم ذلكم قولكم
بافواهكم والله يقول الحق وهو يهدي السبيل
ادعوهم
لابائهم هو اقسط عند
الله فان لم تعلموا
اباءهم فاخوانكم في الدين
ومواليكم وليس عليكم جناح فيما اخطاتم به
ولكن ما تعمدت
قلوبكم وكان الله غفورا
رحيما النبي اولى بالمؤمنين من
انفسهم
وازواجه
امهاتهم واولو الارحام بعضهم اولى ببعض في
كتاب الله من المؤمنين
والمهاجرين الا ان
تفعلوا الا ان تفعلوا الى
اوليائكم
معروفا كان ذلك في الكتاب
مستورا واذ اخذنا من النبيين ميثاقهم ومنك
ومن نوح وابراهيم وموسى وعيسى ابن مريم
واخذنا منهم ميثاقا
غليظا ليسال الصادقين عن صدقهم واعد
للكافر
عذابا اليما يا ايها الذين امنوا اذكروا
نعمه الله عليكم اذ
جاءتكم
جنود اذ
جاءتكم جنود فارسلنا عليهم ريحا وجنودا لم
تروها وكان الله بما تعملون
بصيرا اذ
جاءوا
من فوقكم ومن اسفل
منكم واذ زاغت الابصار وبلغت القلوب
الحناجر
وتظنون بالله الظنونا
هنالك ابتلي المؤمنون وزلزلوا
زلزالا
شديدا واذ يقول المنافقون والذين في
قلوبهم
مرض ما وعدنا الله ورسوله الا
غرورا واذ قال
الطائفه منهم يا اهل يثرب لا مقام لكم
فارجعوا ويستا هذن فريق منهم النبي يقولون
ان بيوتنا عوره وما هي بعوره ان يريدون
الا فرارا ولو دخلت عليهم من اقطارها ثم
سئلوا الفتنه لاتوها وما تلبثوا بها الا
يسيرا ولقد كانوا عاهدوا الله من قبل لا
يولون
الادبار وكان عهد الله
مسؤولا قل لن ينفعكم الفرار ان فررتم من
الموت او القتل واذا لا تمتعون الا
قليلا قل من ذا الذي يعصمكم من الله ان
اراد بكم
سوء او اراد بكم رحمه ولا يجدون لهم من
دون الله وليا ولا
نصيرا قد يعلم الله المعوقين من م
والقائلين لاخوانهم هلم الينا ولا ياتون
الباس الا
قليلا اشحه عليكم فاذا
جاء الخوف رايتهم ينظرون اليك تدور اعينهم
كالذي يغشى عليه من
الموت فاذا ذهب الخوف سلقوكم
بالسنه
حداد اشحه على الخير
اولئك لم يؤمنوا فاحبط الله
اعمالهم وكان ذلك على الله
يسيرا يحسبون الاحزاب لم يذهبوا وان يات
الاحزاب يودوا لو
انهم بادون في الاعرا يسالون عن
انباؤكم
ولو كانوا فيكم ما قاتلوا الا
قليلا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
امين لقد كان لكم في رسول الله اسوه حسنه
لمن كان يرجو الله واليوم الاخر وذكر الله
كثيرا ولما راى المؤمنون الاحزاب قالوا
هذا ما وعدنا الله ورسوله وصدق الله
ورسوله وما زادهم الا ايمانا
وتسليما من المؤمنين رجال صدقوا ما عاهدوا
الله
عليه فمنهم من قضى نحبه ومنهم من
ينتظر وما بدلوا
تبديلا ليجزي الله الص قين بصدقهم ويعذب
المنافقين ان
شاء او يتوب عليهم ان الله كان غفورا
رحيما ورد الله الذين كفروا بغيظهم لم
ينالوا خيرا وكفى الله المؤمنين
القتال وكان الله قويا
عزيزا
وانزل الذين ظاهروهم من اهل الكتاب من
صياصيهم وقذف في قلوبهم
الرعب وقذف في قلوبهم الرعب فريقا تقتلون
وتاسر
فريقا واورثكم ارضهم وديارهم
واموالهم وارضا لم تطؤوها
وكان الله على كل شيء
قديرا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استقيم الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وال اذا يغشى والنهار اذا تجلى وما
خلق الذكر
والانثى ان سعيكم
لشتى فاما من اعطى واتقى وصدق بالحسنى
فسنيسره
لليسرى واما من بخل واستغنى وكذب بالحسنى
للعسر
وما يغني عنه ماله اذا تردى ان علينا
للهدى وان لنا للاخره
والاولى فانذرتكم نارا تلظى لا يصلاها الا
الاشقى الذي كذب
وتولى
وسيجنبها الاتقى الذي يؤتي ماله يتزكى وما
لاحد عنده من
نعمه
تجزى وما لاحد
عنده من نعمه تجزى الا
ابتغاء وجه ربه الاعلى ولسوف
يرضى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين انا انزلناه في ليله القدر وما ادراك
ما ليله القدر ليله القدر خير من الف شهر
تنزل
الملائكه والروح فيها باذن
ربهم من كل امر
سلام هي حتى مطلع الفجر الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف
عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا
اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا اللهم
بلغنا ليله القدر واكتب لنا ثوابها اللهم
اعتقنا من النار اللهم اعتقنا من النار
اللهم اعتقنا من النار وادخلنا الجنه
برحمتك يا عزيز يا
غفار ربنا لا تجعلنا فتنه للقوم
الظالمين ونجنا برحمتك من القوم
الكافرين اللهم انا نسالك العفو والعافيه
في الدنيا
الاخره اللهم عافنا في ابداننا وعافنا في
اسماعنا وعافنا في
ابصارنا
اللهم وفقنا لخيري الدنيا
والاخره اللهم انا نعوذ بك من درك الشقاء
وسوء القضاء وشماته الاعداء ونعوذ بك
اللهم من السلب بعد العطاء اللهم دبر لنا
فانا لا نحسن التدبير واختر لنا فانا لا
نحسن
الاختيار اللهم انا نسالك باسمك الاعظم
الذي اذا دعيت به اجبت واذا سئلت به اعطيت
ان تغفر لنا ولابائنا
ومهات ولاصحاب الحقوق علينا وللمؤمنين
والمؤمنات والمسلمين وال المسلمات احياء
وامواتا وان تعجل بنصرك رح ورحمتك ومددك
لاخواننا المستضعفين في كل مكان في غزه
والسودان وفي بقاع الارض جميعا يا رب
العالمين اللهم اطعمهم من جوع وامنهم من
خوف اللهم دبر لهم اللهم كد لهم اللهم
ادرا عنهم كيد الخائنين
وكيد المعتدين وكيد
الظالمين اللهم عليك بالظالمين يا رب
العالمين اقتلهم بددا واحصهم عددا ولا تذر
منهم احدا انهم يا رب لا يعجزونك وصلى
الله وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
ان